you or someone you care about may have
been diagnosed with leukemia this video
will help you understand some of the
available treatment
options leukemia is a cancer that
originates from blood cells while they
are forming usually white blood
cells in leukemia blood forming cells in
the bone marrow make many cancerous
white blood cells that don't work
properly this weakens your immune system
[Music]
your doctor will make a treatment plan
specifically for your
leukemia it will be based on the type of
leukemia your symptoms age overall state
of health and other
factors treatment options may include
one or more of the following
chemotherapy radiation
therapy targeted therapy
immunotherapy and stem cell transplant
chemotherapy uses drugs that travel
through the bloodstream to kill fast
growing cells like cancer
cells another treatment option is
radiation therapy it uses radiation to
kill cancer cells or stop them from
growing the target area of the radiation
varies depending on the stage and type
of leukemia the type of radiation
therapy used for leukemia is external
radiation it uses a machine that aims
radiation at the cancer from outside the
body targeted therapy uses drugs that
aim for specific targets or markers on
cancer
cells since cancer cells may have more
of these markers than normal cells do
targeted therapy may affect cancer cells
more than normal cells when targeted
therapy drugs attached to the markers on
cancer cells the cancer cells may stop
growing and
dividing immunotherapy can help your
immune system fight
leukemia for example monoclonal
antibodies are laboratory produced
versions of proteins that your immune
system makes to fight bacteria viruses
chemicals and other foreign substances
monoclonal antibodies can be designed to
attach to markers on leukemia cells and
become part of the immune system
attacking the leukemia when attached to
immune cells monoclonal antibodies can
help recognize and destroy the leukemia
cells a stem cell transplant replaces
blood forming cells that were damaged or
destroyed during your cancer treatment
with either your or a healthy donor stem
cells first healthy stem cells are
collected from you or a donor then the
stem cells are stored while you receive
treatment for cancer such as
chemotherapy or radiation
to kill all your blood cells after these
treatments are complete the healthy stem
cells are given to you in your body
these stem cells provide a healthy
supply of future blood
cells your doctor May prescribe a
combination of the treatments we've
discussed or different treatment options
than those mentioned
here as you deal with a diagnosis of
leukemia continue to talk to your doctor
and your Cancer Care
team